a few months ago I moved to a small farm
here in Central Texas and as part of
that process I inherited well some
traditional Farm cats hey buddy
now here's the thing with these cats I
don't really know where they sleep or
where they go or even what they do
during the day and in this video that's
exactly what I'm gonna figure out with
the help of the insta360 go 3 camera now
hopefully with the help of this camera
I'll be able to figure out where these
cats go where they sleep at night and
and generally what they do so I can take
better care of them first I have to fly
to Los Angeles because Ren is going to
help me put together a little now hear
my name red yeah what's up what is that
oh dude this is the new insta360 go 3.
it's not a 360 camera it's more like a
tiny little micro GoPro it's tiny how is
it hanging on there oh I've just got you
know magnetic chest can I just install
the magnetic plate in my chest you know
just like right through here so it just
it sticks right here wow you're
committed I am wait are you wanting to
put this on a cat yes oh dude yes we
should absolutely do that do they hunt
do they hunt nice they hunt mice they
hunt grasshoppers I'd like to at least
figure out where it sleeps that would
make me feel better just knowing that
I'm down all right we're gonna put this
camera on a farm cat
what up son I'll be right back I need a
stapler I need a stapler I need a
stapler Daniel I need a stapler give it
to me
[Music]
is that safe for your bones man dude
that worked by the way since I got you I
figured I might as well tell you a
little bit about this camera I've
literally got a dangling from a crowbar
right now
probably one of the coolest things about
this camera is the bass that it comes
with like this little thing here this
little pivot stand and I'm gonna put
this
like it just snaps in it's magnetic but
it also clasps clasps like I'm filming
on the action pod right now but I can
just disconnect that and this thing here
I can literally just pop the lens out
and attaches just like that wireless
preview too by the way
it sticks anywhere gecko feet right
additionally if you actually scratch the
lens here they make little uh lens
attachments this is like a little glass
filter that you just put on top of the
lens here so if your camera is to get
damaged it's going to damage the filter
and not the lens which is the important
part the main thing to note is that this
camera makes it incredibly easy to get
shots by mounting it anywhere you want
mounting it on your hats mounting it
pretty much anywhere on the little
sticks they give you they have so many
different mounting options that it's
super easy to get any shot you need to
get and that's where the final step
comes in which is editing with the AI
editing tools built into the insta 360
app I don't need to in fact last weekend
I descended down an entire Mountain
outside of La here and I just told the
app to edit a video for me and this is
that what you're looking at right now is
what that thing edited I made no
corrections to it at all I didn't even
change the music this is like ready to
go for Instagram or Tick Tock or
threads I hope what I build here is
going to be useful fortunately Nick also
has a cat so I'm going to send this home
with him tonight so that he can figure
out if it actually is usable or not I'm
gonna hand this off to you Nick
I took this vest rig that Ren made home
to test it on my cat
you want to try this camera buddy
and as soon as I put them in this vest
rig it like constricted his shoulder
blades and he started just like like he
could kind of walk but you could tell
was uncomfortable and chafing and he
just wanted to lay down that's the thing
like the angle is good but he had no
Mobility right and no will to move but I
love that angle I mean
oh and you see how it's rocking back and
forth
but it's definitely like rocking as his
shoulder blades move you put it in free
frame mode uh it'll lock the Horizon
yeah he's like not really sure what's
going on and then he just wanted to lay
down he didn't want to do anything Nick
I think came up with a better solution
because it's such a simpler solution but
so elegant I just got his collar maybe
we can just clip this right on the
collar but it was like flipping around a
lot so I just put a piece of Balsam in
there so I'm hoping this thing will keep
the camera from going this way to and
fro are you ready
all right we are rolling good boy hey
boy
oh where's it going
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good
it's like the cat the first person game
right first person cat yeah this is
insane to me too just like seeing what
my cat sees
he like kills it oh wow kills it and
then he grabs it and brings it to me
thank you
this is like this little game he plays
with me he's like oh he's coming he's
coming he hides under the bed
and then he waits for me to come in
foreign
thanks for helping us be a camera cat I
mean even this footage is like a new
angle that I've never seen before yeah
of a cat like just this test footage so
dude if you can catch a cat actually
hunting yeah that would be so cool if I
put this one on Junior who's the gray
tabby cat who's the most outdoorsy I
think we'll get the best footage from
him because I don't know where he goes
or where he even sleeps dude you gotta
find out so what's crazy about this is
that the preview actually continues
after you pull the camera out so the
preview is still going so I could put
this camera over here
you know and we're still seeing the live
preview on this camera I can literally
just take this camera out and stick it
to anything that's magnetic and it'll
just stick there that's like super
convenient on its own not only do you
have like a little selfie stick this can
bend and you can put it around stuff
like
whoa
and it's 100 waterproof the camera is
waterproof the action pod is water
resistant so don't submerge the entire
thing but the little pod itself throw it
in a lake all right well I actually do
have to grab my bag because I have to
get on the flight here you go thank you
I will treat it like my own child I will
put it on my cats and can't wait for
this man I think we're gonna get some
great shots have a safe flight bye Vlog
loud on that thing all right
howdy
Through Your Eyes
Junior
hi Junior hey buddy look who I found
napping in the barn and this is the
perfect opportunity to put both the
harness rig and the simple collar rig on
him to see which one he likes best what
do you think bud
all right how do you like that Junior
can you move in that
not so much
okay Junior says no but I'm hoping that
the collar rig will be a little bit more
conducive to him oh hey look at that
look at that he's moving look who's the
Conquering Hero but it looks like this
is our rig he's moving around and he
seems pretty comfortable with it
comfortable enough that I think he'll
tolerate 15 minutes of filming here and
there at a time
[Music]
foreign
okay I found out where he is most of the
time because of the go 3 camera he
sleeps in the street he sleeps right
right here on these Limbs and he likes
to come in here every day probably
because it's cool and shaded there's
shelter and well he's got some company
not not too bad I ain't mad at it
[Music]
he was also getting into the chicken
coop I had some concerns about that you
know maybe he was going to eat the eggs
or mess with the chickens
laughs
but no they they seem to get along just
fine
okay I've been putting the cat's food
here in the barn and I had some concern
that he wasn't finding it so I put a
camera on him and sure enough you know
boom he discovered the food right there
that's a good thing however when I was
looking at the footage of The Cat in the
barn
he discovered a rat
I've never seen one in here I don't know
whether or not it had been in here a
long time or whether it was just passing
through but either way it seems Junior
found a rat but ultimately didn't do
anything about it
[Music]
thank you
oh what do you got there Junior what did
you catch Junior
now upon discovery of that footage I
realized that my cat Junior well
maybe he's not as good of a mouse hunter
as he should be but you know who is my
dog Abby
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
when I'm gone she goes to places I never
knew existed
[Music]
[Applause]
watching through this footage opened up
a whole new perspective for me and I'm
not just talking visually this farm this
isn't just their home this is their
world and I'm glad to have had the
opportunity to see it from their view
wait is that a deer leg
oh well that's country living for you
course this entire video wouldn't have
been possible without a camera as
Compact and long lasting as the go three
[Music]
well it has been a journey filming this
video this week when we sought out we
wanted to discover things like where do
these cats sleep what do they do during
the day who are they around which
animals are they nearby and can we
better take care of them by better
understanding who they are and what they
do and I feel like we've absolutely
accomplished that with the insta360 go
3. thanks to Junior and Abby for
participating so if you're interested in
picking up one of these insta360 go 3s
for yourself the links in the
description below once again thanks to
them for sponsoring and for building
this amazing camera and uh see you next
time
[Music]
thank you